some nevada school athletes are really
thrilled with the new directives
involving high school
contact sports and allowing football to
return in some districts that's
important
but many athletes are still sidelined
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with more on what
might be confusing to some and a bit
hypocritical to others chris
yeah it really might be brian there in
nevada 16 school districts charter
schools and private schools will be
allowed to play
spring football bishop gorman faith
lutheran will be playing
schools in moapa and schools north up in
reno and all of northern nevada
but the ccsd schools are still benched
no full
full contact sports ccsd's officially
opted out
no sports until face-to-face instruction
now joining me live is rich morocco head
football coach at liberty high school
rich i really appreciate you joining us
here tonight i want your reaction to the
governor's new directives here
well um that's the first step that we
needed to have happen
so from that regard i'm happy i'm glad
that um
you know the nfhs recommended lowering
the risk of football
and the governor uh took the advice of
the niaaa and opened it back up for
most of the state i got a question for
you have you ever had
kids who have been homeschooled or who
have enrolled in virtual schooling and
then have been allowed to play football
for you
yes well that is that has always been a
rule that's been in place that as long
as you live in your
uh zoned attendance area you could you
could play for
a team if you're charter school or if
you're uh if you were home school or
virtual school
if you know if you didn't offer that so
uh at liberty we have had several people
through the years that uh were able to
participate
well the big question now would be then
why can't they play now
yeah that's that's kind of what we were
wondering you know back in the summer
uh the football coaches association we
we asked for a plan to maybe start in
september
allow us to play even though we're not
in school
um because the kids technically are in
school they're going to school they're
taking class they're
they're they're being graded it's just
they're not physically in the building
and uh you know we were told that the
the niaa
board of control and the superintendents
uh wanted people to be in the buildings
so it was a little disappointing for us
rich final question does there need to
be
in-person learning say five days a week
or say two days a week to play high
school sports in your opinion
uh from my understanding it's as long as
we're in a hybrid situation so if we're
back two days a week
i think that'll be good enough and
listening to the niaaa
call today um they might even open up an
appeal process
uh so you know we're hoping that maybe
the the ccsd we'll
we'll take a look at that all right
there he is thank you very much rich
morocco head football coach at liberty
high school
so thousands of kids here in southern
nevada won't be playing fall sports this
spring
while they wait for district approval
might add this affects the most student
athletes fall sports
has the most participants of all the
seasons